un ecologista calcula la edad de 100
árboles en un bosque local él usa una
gráfica de caja y bigotes para mostrar
sus datos como se muestra a continuación
cuál es el rango de edad de los árboles
cuál es la media de la edad de un árbol
del bosque primero que nada vamos a
asegurarnos de entender lo que nos dice
esta gráfica de caja y bigotes esa es
una manera de ver ampliamente el
conjunto de datos en este caso la edad
de los árboles y también nos da otra
información como por ejemplo cuál es la
media y donde se encuentra la mayor
parte de las edades de los árboles y
estas partes de los bigotes
este es un bigote esta es la caja o
cajas y aquí hay otro bigote en esencia
lo que nos dice unos bigotes es cómo se
diseminen los datos que tenemos aquí el
punto más bajo de nuestros datos un
árbol de ocho años asumiendo que éste
deje de acá se refiere a la edad en años
y el árbol más viejo es de 50 años si
queremos el rango rango desde el punto
de vista estadístico
el dato mayor menos el dato menor así
que será 50 menos 8 es igual a un rango
de 42 y esto es lo que nos dicen los
bigotes nos dice que todos los datos
están entre 8 y 50 incluyendo los 8 y 50
años ahora lo que hacen las cajas
vemos primero esta línea de en medio
esta es la mediana vamos a escribir la
mediana
por lo que la mitad de las edades van a
estar de este lado de la mediana
vemos que la mediana es de 21 esta
gráfica de cajas y bigotes nos dicen que
la mitad de las edades de los árboles
son menores que 21 y la otra mitad son
mayores que 21 y esos puntos de las
cajas esas son las medianas de cada una
de estas secciones
así que esta es la mediana para todos
los árboles que están por debajo de 21
años
y esa es la mitad de la edad de todos
los árboles que son mayores a 21 años
y esencialmente se está dividiendo la
información en cuatro grupos
esto vamos a llamarle el primer cuarto
con 1
o mejor escribimos 1 q que es el primer
cuarto que es aproximadamente un cuarto
de los árboles caen en esta parte otro
cuarto de los árboles van a caer entre
14 y 21 otro cuarto va a estar dentro de
21 y 33 y el último cuarto va a caer en
esta parte aquí tenemos un cuarto dos
cuartos tres cuartos y el cuarto cuarto
para responder la pregunta de cuál es el
rango de edades es de 42 años
distribuidos entre el árbol más joven y
el árbol más viejo y la edad mediana de
un árbol del bosque es de 21 años aunque
tenemos árboles que son tan viejos como
de 50 años la media del bosque es más
cercana a la mitad más baja o más joven
de todo el espectro de edades si vemos
la mediana como nuestra medida de la
tendencia central está a 21 años y
visualmente podemos ver que está más
cerca hacia la izquierda del final del
bigote izquierdo que de lo que
del final del bigote derecho